The Global Occult Coalition, better known
as the GOC, are a group of bloodthirsty, gun-toting
cowboys who shoot first and ask questions
later.
Whether it’s a helpful sentient chair or
a little girl whose only anomalous quality
is manifesting flowers and ice cream, the
GOC have only one response: Destroy.
Burn it, crush it, shoot it in the face with
extreme prejudice and be home in time for
dinner.
Or at least, that’s what plenty of SCP Foundation
Devotees would have you believe.
But if we only judged an organization by the
words of its greatest opponents, we’d be
dealing with an extremely one-sided picture.
Are they gung ho morons who regularly blunder
into complex situations, and make everything
worse with either plain ignorance or outright
malice?
Or are they humanity’s true defenders, working
on behalf of the world’s democratically
elected leaders rather than the unaccountable
mystery of The Foundation?
As with most things in life, the answer is
often found somewhere in the middle.
That’s why today, we’re going to take
a closer look at the United Nations’ answer
to the anomalous threats that inhabit our
world.
Who are they?
What do they believe?
And what are some of their greatest victories
and failures?
The inception of what we now know as the Global
Occult Coalition began during the Seventh
Occult War, which occurred during World War
II.
The Nazi SS Ahnenerbe and the Thule-Gesselschaft
attempted to complete a ritual known as the
Rite of Solomon, which would have given them
terrifying supernatural power.
This was the first time that a number of world
governments understood the true scope of the
paranormal threat out there, and after the
war concluded - with many dead - they wanted
to make sure this could never happen again.Of
course, the SCP Foundation works in cooperation
with all world governments, but ultimately,
they still have autonomy.
And no one nation could ever shoulder the
responsibility of protecting all of humanity,
either, lest nationalism and self-interest
get in the way of the mission.
The United Nations needed their own organization,
that was completely accountable to them and
them alone in order to protect themselves
from paranormal threats - or “Parathreats”.
And thus, the Global Occult Coalition was
born.
As the “coalition” part of the name suggests,
the GOC is an umbrella term for 108 different
paranormal organizations - all gathered under
the shared goal of protecting humanity from
parathreats and fostering continued positive
relationships between paranormal groups.
Its member groups include, but are in no way
limited to: The Bavarian Illuminati, The International
Center for the Study of Unified Thaumatology,
The Reformed Holy Order of the Knights Templar,
Servants of the Silicon Nornir, The United
Church of Satan - Science Division, The World
Parahealth Organization, and The Universalist
Order of the Æsir.
Yeah, it’s a lot to take in.
But don’t worry, there won’t be a quiz
later.
These groups and many more unite under the
Global Occult Coalition’s “Fivefold Mission.”
Understanding these five missions is vital
to understanding why the GOC works in the
way it does, and why it differs from the Foundation.
Mission One: Survival - This is the primary
directive of the GOC, ensuring the survival
of humanity in the face of parathreats.
Mission Two: Concealment - Much like the Foundation,
the GOC seeks to conceal knowledge of parathreats
from the public that could cause mass panic
or loss of life.
Mission Three: Protection - In an interesting
departure from the somewhat colder Foundation
perspective, the GOC also prizes the safety
of individual humans, including its own personnel.
Mission Four: Destruction - This mission is
perhaps the biggest difference between the
GOC and the Foundation, and is often what
defines them in the public eye.
The GOC considers the very existence of parathreats
to be a danger to the survival of humanity,
so no risks are taken to ensure their survival.
And finally, Mission Five: Education - The
GOC seeks to expand their knowledge base in
regards to the parathreats they face across
the globe.
Clearly, the Global Occult Coalition knows
where they stand.
Many have positioned the GOC as villains to
the Foundation’s more level-headed approach,
but arguments could also be made in the GOC’s
favor when it comes to killing off rather
than studying anomalies.
The number of deaths caused in containment
breaches of parathreats that could have been
executed immediately after being captured
is one persuasive argument, as is the continued
potential threat of parathreats currently
sitting in containment.
And while the GOC has been called inhumane
for its desire to murder parathreats, ask
any member of D-Class Personnel whether the
SCP Foundation is a more ethical organization
in comparison.
While the Foundation are generally far more
considerate with anomalies than the GOC, their
attitude towards their human cannon fodder
is just as cold.
Of course, we’re not saying either organization
is right or wrong in this instance - more
that it’s a nuanced issue that’s difficult
to look at in terms of morality.
Later, we’ll take a look at two of the most
famous case studies to see how the GOC’s
methodology plays out on the field.
But first, let’s take a look at how the
actual organization is structured.
At the top of the tower is the Council of
108.
Much like the United Nations, this Council
is made up of representatives from each of
the 108 member organizations of the GOC.
Below that is the High Command, headed by
the mysterious Under-Secretary-General D.C.
al Fine - believed to be a woman who is living
somewhere in Europe - as well as The Nexus.
The Nexus directs a network of Command Central
hubs to coordinate and support local operations.
Below that, the GOC is separated into three
prongs: The PHYSICS Division, the PSYCHE Division,
and the PTOLEMY Division.The PHYSICS division
is the action arm of the GOC, made up of Assessment
Teams and Strike Teams.
It’s their job to investigate and capture
or neutralize parathreats.
The PSYCHE Division is the diplomatic sector
of the GOC, and consists of Special Observers
and Ambassadors - these personnel maintain
relationships between paranormal groups, and
keeps things smooth between normal humanity
and the Occult.
The PTOLEMY Division is known as the support
arm, and is home to the Quartermasters and
the Research and Development department.
This division helps the other two divisions
do their work - from managing logistics and
resource distribution, to developing state
of the art weapons and equipment for GOC personnel.
One more quick note before we move onto two
of the GOC’s greatest hits: It’s important
to know that the GOC classifies anomalies
different to how the SCP Foundation does.
Rather than SCPs, the GOC refers to them as
TEs, or Threat Entities.
While the GOC employs a frankly baffling number
of code words for various groups, ideas, or
concepts that we don’t have the time to
get into right now, we can tell you the main
types of TEs.
There are KTEs - or “Known Threat Entities.”
UTE - or “Unknown Threat Entities.”
PTEs - “Potential Threat Entities.”
And LTEs - or “Liquidated Threat Entities”,
which are Threat Entities they have confirmed
to be destroyed.
Now, you should have a pretty good idea of
who the Global Occult Coalition is - their
member organizations, their mission statements,
their major ideological differences from the
SCP Foundation.
But it’s a common truism that actions speak
louder than words, so we need to talk about
two of the most infamous incidents in the
organization's history.
First, there’s the chair.
Known as KTE-0937-Velveteen or "Sixth Chair"
to the Global Occult Coalition, and SCP - 1609
to the SCP Foundation.
This is an incident that the Foundation and
Foundation supporters love to cite when criticizing
the GOC.
From their telling, 1609 was an innocent,
if a little spooky-looking chair with a harmless
anomalous property - It teleports behind people
who want to sit down.
In spite of how helpful and benign this is,
the Global Occult Coalition did what they
always do and decided to neutralize it by
forcing it into a woodchipper.
However, this didn’t actually kill the chair,
it merely transformed it into a collection
of sentient wood chips with an understandable
chip on its shoulder.
Now, when angered - typically by mentions
of things related to the GOC, or by the sound
of motors running - these chips teleport into
people’s lungs, causing fatal organ damage.
Surely this shows that the GOC are a bunch
of haphazard idiots - they transformed a harmless
anomaly into a killer!
Well, it’s not that simple.
According to their own telling of the incident
with the Sixth Chair, it was exactly that:
Just the sixth in a number of other parathreats
being destroyed because of their relation
to a dangerous parathreat creator known as
The Carpenter.
All five other items were successfully incinerated
- the chair was only unsuccessfully neutralized
with the woodchipper due to a machine error
with the incinerator.
In other words, what is often painted as a
prime example of GOC brashness and incompetence
could just as easily have been a total accident
that occurred during an otherwise logical
action.
No different from the fatalities that often
occur during an SCP Foundation containment
breach.
But let’s look at another example: SCP - 1522,
known to the GOC as LTE-4201-Velveteen, or
the "Ghost Ships.”
The Foundation often cites this as being another
textbook example of the GOC taking things
too far, and murdering a completely innocent
anomaly minding its own business.
This anomaly was two apparently sapient boats
in the middle of the ocean that showed compassion
for one another, giving them the reputation
of being literal love boats.
The GOC apparently objected to this union
and blew one of the boats to kingdom come,
leaving the other to self-terminate in grief.
How can the GOC possibly come out as anything
but monsters in this scenario - harming two
wholesome anomalies that would never hurt
a fly?
Well, don’t be so sure about that.
From the GOC report, we can first see that
the boats were already encroaching into human
territory, leading to reports of “ghost
ships“ from fishermen trawling in that area.
And while the GOC did admittedly fire the
first shot, it cannot be denied that the surviving
ship’s retaliation was equally if not more
violent than the initial attack.
Upon attacking the first of the two ships,
the second wilfully collided with the GOC
vessel, manned by the Strike Team Ocean Thunder,
at hypersonic speeds.
This killed the entire GOC team present.
While it’s easy to say that this attack
was in self-defense, it also shows that the
boats always had devastating combat potential
if provoked.
If the parathreat had performed this same
act on a larger Navy ship, or on a cruise
ship or any kind of commercial vessel, hundreds
of lives would be lost.
Doesn’t seem so innocent now, does it?
What conclusion can we draw from all this?
Is the Global Occult Coalition a gaggle of
bloodthirsty idiots looking to kill off anomalies
for the sake of it?
No.
Are they a morally perfect organization, protecting
human survival and the quality of human life
from a Foundation that couldn’t care less?
The answer is “no” here too.
While the SCP Foundation and the GOC have
been known to squabble, and have caused even
more damage to one another in alternate realities,
they’re ultimately two sides of the same
coin.
The two have even been known to reluctantly
collaborate when necessary.
Perhaps they don’t always see eye to eye,
especially on some of the smaller and more
contentious anomalies, but in a world where
cosmic nightmares are lurking just behind
the fabric of our reality and some are preparing
to strike, it feels comforting to have both
of them at the ready.
Now go check out our playlist on the epic
saga of SCP - 5000, The Suit, and a world
where the SCP and the GOC really come to blows.
And don’t forget to subscribe and tell us
in the comments which piece of SCP lore you
want to see next!